[Musique]
montceau a ravi de retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat dans dix
jours ce sera le coup d'envoi du
baccalauréat l'examen pourrait bien être
perturbée en raison d'un appel à la
grève une dizaine de syndicats
enseignants appellent à boycotter la
surveillance des épreuves de philosophie
et de france est à l'origine de cette
colère notamment la récente du lycée du
baccalauréat du ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer
et pour en parler j'accueille autour de
cette table deux invités marie agnès du
robot soir bonsoir à vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques au lycée
dumont-d'urville de maurepas vous êtes
également commissaire paritaire au sein
du snalc versailles le snalc c'est le
syndicat national des lycées et collèges
en face de vous diana kobayashi bonsoir
vous êtes président de la pub de
versailles je rappelle que la pub c'est
la fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public merci en tout cas
à toutes les deux d'être présente ce
soir alors marianne et du rouge lui
tourne vers vous puisque votre syndicat
a appelé à se mobiliser le 17 juin
on parlera notamment des raisons dans
quelques minutes
pourquoi cette date du 17 juin pourquoi
choisir donc cette date parce que nous
avons déjà tenté d'instaurer un dialogue
avec le ministère
nous avons déjà essayé de
proposez des évolutions des changements
faut pas croire que les syndicats
souhaitent hostiles au changement mais
en réalité il y à un dialogue de sourds
c'est à dire que il y a une belle
communication au niveau du ministère
mais tout ce que nous essayons de dire
pour la réalité du terrain les
conditions d'enseignement des personnels
les conditions de travail des élèves
aussi ne sont pas écoutés et en réalité
il n'ya aucune modification par rapport
aux projets initiaux
cela reste j'ai envie de dire lettre
morte donc nous avons choisi le
baccalauréat
tout un symbole ammi ahmed pour un
message fort j'imagine pour un message
fort pour nous on a consulté tous nos
adhérents pour savoir quel était le mode
d'action qu'il préférait est plutôt que
de défiler dans la rue avec une image
violente nous avons choisi un symbole de
boycotter les surveillances du 17 juin
alors au centre de votre fédération
l'apep comment vous avez accueilli cette
nouvelle
nous partageons les inquiétudes des
enseignants nous les comprenons
par contre
nous déplorons quand même
cette manière puisque on pense qu'il ya
une possibilité d'avoir d'autres moyens
d'action
surtout que les analystes sont assez
stressés déjà on le sait que
les élèves
doué prix pour certains sons qui sont
priorisées quand même donc s'en sortir
mais d'autres pas donc c'est dommage a
commencé en fait sur cette note
leur épreuve très très importante des
parents d'élèves on prend cette
inquiétude en même temps nous avons déjà
en fait mener toutes sortes d'actions et
c'est bien parce que celles qui ont été
précédentes n'ont mené
rien que nous avons choisi ce mode là
cependant il faut pas croire que nous
avons donné les élèves au contraire
c'est le souci même des élèves pas
seulement d'ailleurs ceux de cette année
mais tous les autres nous nous battons
tous les jours
à leurs côtés deux seront parmi les
premiers à aller avec eux pour regarder
les résultats
comme nous sommes inquiets de voir si
notre travail parce que les élèves
évidemment son seul le jour du bac face
à leur copie mais c'est tout le travail
du professeur tout le travail avec sa
classe tout le travail qu'il a pu mettre
en place malgré les conditions pas
toujours faciles qui sont récompensés
j'ai envie de dire quand il voit aussi
les élèves réussir mais pas simplement
pour le baccalauréat parce que il faut
voir qu'il ya parfois eu déjà des
changements dans les années précédentes
une photocopie mal fait il avait fallu
refaire les épreuves donc le bac ils
vont le passé c'est un examen par un
concours mais nous avons choisi cette
date symbolique pour attirer l'attention
justement pour que ce soit visible du
ministère parce que c'est eux qui ont
aussi la charge d'organiser la
surveillance vous j'ai fait est très
répondre bah je jean-michel à bancaire
s'est exprimé à ce sujet ils
s'organisent ils prévoient donc je pense
que le bac
va pas se passer comme les douces comme
ça ça doit y être
par contre nous les parents d'élèves
on est quand même à vos côtés nous
partageons tout à fait nouveau et
inquiétude et je trouve que c'est
dommage parce que justement il ya sept
et à ses frontières qui va se creuser
creuser entre nous et vous ont dit que
nous battons pour la même cause alors
justement la cause on va parler un petit
peu du fond puisque rappelle vous êtes
notamment opposés à la réforme du lycée
et la réforme du bac 2021 donc ça vous
partagez justement ces inquiétudes en
tout à fait
les élèves qui sont aujourd'hui on sait
grande vous le confirmer c'est très
souvent on s'éteint les les appels on
tourne avec les séries voilà vont êtres
vont être supprimés ils referont commun
il y aura des enseignements de
spécialité la spatialité en fait c'est
pareil ça va creuser encore plus en
penser les disparités entre les airs
puisque ya déjà aujourd'hui à 2,78
l'elysée que sont déjà spécialisées
scientifiques littéraires ça va
continuer avec les spécialités
donc sauf que il y aura beaucoup moi
d'approfondissement
pour les élèves et puis certains ce qui
est là encore le cas aujourd'hui
déjà ils ont du mal à choisir entre ssl
choisir son avenir en seconde c'est très
compliqué là encore c'est les élèves qui
sont qui sont bien accompagnés par les
parents qui vont être avantagée par les
autres et nous on a peut être
soutient tous les airs que la réussite
de tous les élèves et dans le 78 on le
sait qu'il ya des disparités entre les
communes et je pense que c'est le vans
et peuvent se creuser encore plus alors
qu'est ce qui ne va pas finalement selon
vous dans cette réforme c'est très
simple du bac
alors il ya plusieurs choses déjà un il
faut voir pour avoir d enseignement de
qualité
il faut aussi avoir des professeurs de
qualité et à l'heure actuelle nous
sommes dans une académie qui est
sinistrée sur ce point là on manque de
professeurs et de professeurs de qualité
notre hymne une aération n'est pas
attractive que ce rêve que ce soit si on
se compare par rapport aux autres pays
que ce soit si on se compare par rapport
aux autres fonctions publiques
donc on a besoin d' enseignement de
qualité donnés par des professeurs de
qualité
donc c'est pour ça que notre première
revendication c'est la rémunération mais
ensuite vis-à-vis de cette réforme ce
qui ne va pas c'est exactement j'ai
envie de dire comme pour la loi de la
confiance ou la loi bancaire c'est que
tout va très vite
donc il y a beaucoup de communication
mais on ne tient pas compte de la
réalité du terrain
madame l'a très bien dit il va y avoir
une énorme disparité puisque en fonction
des lycées et du nombre d'élèves on
ouvrira ou pas telle spécialité
si la spécialité n'est pas proposée dans
le lycée il faudra que l'élève se
tourner vers un lycée voisin si c'est
possible
nous avons une partie qui est rural si
ça n'est pas un établissement
directement possible vous voyez bien
toutes les difficultés d'accès qu'il
peut y avoir aux spécialités
donc cela va créer effectivement
détention pour tous les élèves que ce
soit les bons élèves comme ceux qui ont
plus de difficultés parce que en fait
ils ne vont pas vraiment choisir ce
qu'ils veulent
leurs projets sont parfois encore flou
mais ils vont choisir ce qu'ils ont à
disposition et ensuite ils vont se
tourner vers leurs professeurs qui
essaye de les conseiller du mieux qu'ils
peuvent
mais nous ne sommes pas
les spécialistes psychologues et
conseillers d'orientation
c'est un autre corps qui est en train de
disparaître également et tout va reposer
sur nous alors que nous allons avoir du
mal à suivre les élèves on en reparlait
en fait quand les spécialités
il n'y aura plus un groupe place pour
toutes les spécialités puisque chaque
élève pourra voir des spécialités
différentes et le suivi assuré à ce
moment là le plus difficile pour chaque
élève est le grand drame si l'on parlait
tout à l'heure ça va être compliqué
aussi puisque les talibans vont changer
de niveau des professeurs
comment ça va se passer dans la classe
avec plusieurs spécialités à on est on
est inquiet mais du coup le ca me
demandez aussi est-ce que vous
pas trouvé d'autres moyens parce que je
comprends que vous défendez votre métier
vous détendre et aussi à le futur de nos
enfants
mais là cette année ça va être compliqué
pour les élèves qui passent par leur
bague aussi c'est déjà compliqué pour
les élèves qui arrivent de seconde et
qui s'inscrivent en première c'est déjà
aussi compliqué pour les élèves qui
passent effectivement le bac et qui sont
encore désorientés face à parcours sup
qui se raccroche et ils le voient que
nous nous battons à leurs côtés mais
c'est compliqué pour les enseignants qui
ont vraiment l'impression d'être
complètement lâchée par l'administration
ce n'est pas nous qui avons creusé le
fossé alors par rapport à son mouvement
du 8 du 17 juin le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a estimé qu'il n'y aurait pas
trop de grévistes vous quel est votre
votre sentiment
vous pensez que ça va être un mouvement
suivi nous appelons tous les enseignants
à faire grève
nous espérons qui sera suivi pour que
nous soyons entendus
j'aime bien le peu suivi ou pas trop
suivi
c'est un mode d'action qui a été choisi
par les collègues
donc nous espérons être le maximum
possible en tout cas nous serons
mobilisés
alors pourquoi justement d'écouter la
réaction de la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles et charline amenait à
venelles pardon par rapport justement à
ce mouvement du 17 juin chaque année
avant le bac
il ya évidemment des des questions qui
se posent sur l'organisation du
baccalauréat l'année dernière y avait
une grève des transports qui était
conséquente l'année d'avant sans doute
encore autre chose cette année il y a
quelques
mouvements sociaux qui sont possibles
tout cas toutes les dispositions sont
prises au niveau de l'éducation
nationale pour faire en sorte que comme
toutes les années le baccalauréat se
passe dans de très bonnes conditions
donc voilà établissement par
établissement nous sommes en train de
nous assurer des groupes de bonnes
conditions pour passer balle donc je
suis sereine iliana kobayashi ce que
vous êtes rassurés par la rectrice
oui donc dû ses ouïes je suis rassuré je
pense que ça va être le cas donc je
l'espère mais du du coup j'ai pas rond
fait que le dialogue soit rompue
également avec vos employeurs et on
pourra pas nous à l'appel quand on
essaie de construire
effectivement je comprends je comprends
vos inquiétudes
votre combat aussi parce que nous sommes
inquiets autant que vous voire plus
puisque là on joue qu'à l'avenir
professionnel de nos enfants de notre
pays mais
je ne dis pas comment vous allez
reprendre le dialogue après pourra
construire autre chose derrière
bientôt à sa fin trente secondes pour
pour quand tu conclure et pour répondre
à madame kobayashi on pourrait déjà et
rétablir les commissions paritaires
supprimé par la loi dite de confiance et
venir s'asseoir autour d'une table de
dialogue parce que nous sommes capables
de comprendre qu'il y à une négociation
à mener et nous sommes capable de la
mener s'il y a un interlocuteur
merci en tout cas toutes les deux d'être
présent d'avoir été présente ce soir
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau ce est vif débat
[Musique]